mon-star coach you scared there's 10,000
people out there that think that we
ain't good enough
win or lose I am so proud of you you're
gonna win what game are we playing
basketball coach what color is this key
why y'all gonna kill those Caucasians
but look at this fundamentals your black
bear white
this ain't hockey something I want to
ask you something I like to ask you will
you mommy wait what do you say I want
you to be my first truth or dare
yeah so you that blond kid over there I
dare you to blow out as candles before
he gets a chance to they homeschool
their side it's very important to us
that Kevin has a normal and complete
high school experience drop your buffs
parfaits hey guys come check out this
kids weird mom why didn't you call me
we did I know after sex you know that
like a baby oh my soul so dark because
you saw some bats when you were little
yeah surprise caught you a leprechaun
who's magically delicious now don't you
superior hide the eye babe is a high
fidelity music player kids are sticking
there you know what's in the Badger pork
fan then mangoes
there be no water good extensive testing
any red flags
hey can I please come in Debbie Clark's
here the girl you asked out it's gonna
be awkward no no wait gosh my 704 just
enough to plug it up
I know some pieces but
can't believe you had sex with that hobo
for magic being he was Weiser
now we understand just when I thought it
couldn't get more offensive
how many times do I have to go you're
black they're white coach what you
saying is we just walk with the Lord did
his part already made you black